in the last video i said that we start
off with let's say we started off with
the change in distance so we said you
know we know the change in distance uh
change
and distance this is the things that we
are given we're given the
acceleration we're given the initial
velocity
and i asked you how do we figure out
what the final velocity is and in the
last video and if you don't remember go
go watch that last video again we
derived the formula that
vf squared
the final velocity squared is equal to
the initial velocity squared plus
2 times the change in distance you'll
sometimes just see written this as 2
times distance because we assumed that
the initial distance is at point zero so
the change in distance would just be the
final distance but
we could write it either way and
hopefully at this point you kind of see
why i keep switching between change and
distance and distance
really just so so
you're comfortable when you see it
either way but what if we this is this
is for the the situation if when we
didn't know what vf is
let's say we want to solve for for time
instead well actually once we solve for
the final velocity we can actually solve
for time and i'll show you how to do
that let's say we didn't want to go
through this step how can we solve for
time directly given the change in
distance the acceleration and the
initial velocity
well let's go back once again to our the
most basic
distance formula not the distance
formula the how distance relates to
velocity so we know that all right
slightly different this time just so the
change
in distance
over the change in time
is equal to
the average velocity
right or we could we could have
rewritten this as
we could rewrite this as
the change in distance is equal to the
average velocity times the change in
time
right this is change in time change in
distance
and sometimes we'll just see this
written as
d equals let me write this in a
different color so we have some variety
sometimes you'll see this is written as
d equals velocity times time or d equals
rate times time and the reason why i
have change in distance here or change
in time is
well i'm not assuming necessarily that
we're starting off at the point zero or
at time zero but if we do then it just
turns out to kind of the final distance
is equal to the average velocity times
the final time but let's stick to this
we want to figure out time given this
set of inputs
so let's go back to well let's go let's
go back to this equation actually let's
go from this equation
right
so if we want to solve for time or the
change in time
we could say
we could just derive both sides we could
divide both sides by the average
velocity
actually you know let's not do that
let's just stay in terms of change in
distance
so let me let me
actually i've wasted space too fast so
let me clear this
and start again
so we're given
we're given
change in distance
we're given initial velocity that's
initial velocity and we're given
acceleration
and we want to figure out what the time
is and if we assume i mean it's really
the change in time but let's just assume
that we start time zero so this is kind
of the final time
so we know that
let's just start with the simple formula
distance or change in distance i'll use
them interchangeably
distance i use a lowercase d this time
is equal to the average velocity
times time
and what's the average velocity
well
that is just
the average velocity is just
the initial velocity
plus the final velocity over two and the
only reason why we can
do it while we can just average the
initial and the finals because we're
assuming constant acceleration that's
very important but in most projectile
problems we do have constant
acceleration downwards and that's
gravity so we can assume we can do this
we can say that the average of the
initial and the final velocity is the
average velocity
and then we multiply that times time
and
well can we use this equation directly
well no we know acceleration but we
don't know final velocity so if we can
write this final velocity in terms of
the other things in this equation then
maybe we can we can solve for time
let's try to do that so well i switched
colors kind of arbitrarily but let's
distance is equal to
well let me let me take a little side
here because what do we know about final
velocity
we know that the change in velocity
the change in velocity is equal to
acceleration times time
right assuming that time starts at t
equals zero
and the change in velocity is the same
thing as vf
minus vi
is equal to acceleration times time
and so we know the final velocity is
equal to the initial velocity plus
acceleration times time right so let's
substitute that back into this
what i was writing right here so we have
distance is equal to the initial
velocity
plus the final velocity so let's
substitute
this expression right here
the initial velocities
plus now the final velocity is the
initial velocity plus acceleration times
time
and then we divide all of that by 2
times time
and so we get d is equal to so let's see
we have 2 in the numerator we have 2
initial velocity
2 v i's
plus
a
t
over 2
all of that
times t
and then we can simplify this
this equals d is equal to let's see this
2 cancel out this 2 so we have and we
multiply we distribute this t across
both terms so d is equal to v
i
t
plus and then this term is a t over two
but then you multiply the t times here
too so it's a t squared over two
plus
a
t squared
over two
so there we could use this formula if we
know the change in distance or the
distance we could say you know we could
say the same thing as the change in this
this actually should be the change in
distance and the change in time is equal
to the initial velocity times time plus
acceleration time squared divided by 2.
so let let me summarize kind of all of
the equations we have because we really
now have in our arsenal every equation
that we that you really need to solve
a one-dimensional projectile problem you
know things going you know either just
left right east west or north south and
not both and we'll do that in the next
video
but let's let's summarize everything we
know
image
so we know
the change
in distance divided by the change in
time is equal to velocity average
velocity
it would equal velocity if velocity is
not changing but average when velocity
does change
and we have constant acceleration that's
an important assumption
we know that the change in velocity
divided by the change
in time
is equal to
acceleration
we know the average velocity
is equal to
the final velocity
plus the initial velocity
over two and this assumes acceleration
is constant
acceleration
constant
if we know the initial velocity the
acceleration and the distance and we
want to figure out
we want to figure out the final velocity
we could go we could
use this formula
v
f
squared
equals v i squared
plus 2
a
times really the change in distance i'm
going to write the change in distance
because that sometimes matters when
we're when we're dealing with the
direction times change in distance but
you'll sometimes just write this as
distance
and then we just did the equation i
think i did this in the third video as
well early on but we also learned that
distance
is equal to the initial velocity
times time
plus
a t squared over 2.
so in that example that i did a couple
of videos ago where we had a cliff
actually i only have a minute left in
this video so i'm going to do that
in the next presentation i'll see you
soon